just mentioned it we are following that
breaking news right now a huge
fire inside a downtown parking garage
overnight las vegas fire and rescue tell
us
several cars were destroyed in that fire
bianca holman is live on scene now with
the very latest good morning bianca what
can you tell us
hey good morning alex five cars
destroyed several others damaged
and this fire that happened in the four
queens parking structure
and you can just see how the fire just
melted through that parking structure
and onto the bus stop
you can see that the bus stop is charred
the top where people wait underneath
while waiting for the bus
somewhat destroyed there and charred
black from that smoke that came out of
that fire
now this happened just before 2 am
outside of the the four queens casino at
casino center in carson
and again several cars destroyed by this
and it took about 20 to 40 minutes for
the
firefighters to fight the fire and put
out the hot spots
check the stairways and the elevators
make sure nobody was inside
and because this is an older parking
structure we're told that there were no
sprinklers to aid
in the combat of the fire when the fire
first started
the biggest risk was the vehicles
themselves they're extremely dangerous
they
produce some of the most deadly gases
known to man when they burn
you have a large supply of gasoline
that's up there and that burns very
intensely
it's underneath that parking deck it's
like an oven more or less
so the amount of heat that was being
produced by those vehicles
were considerably higher than what's
usually found inside of a building fire
and so because of this there's about 500
thousand dollars worth of damage we're
told
and also investigators they'll be back
here on the scene even though they've
cleared right now they'll be back here
later on this morning to investigate the
cause of this fire they do have they
have pinpointed to
the first floor of the parking structure
but again the cause is still unknown so
they'll be back here later on this
morning
to figure that all out back to you guys
in the studio all right